sono abbastanza convinto che la realtà
virtuale prenderà possesso delle nostre
vite
da qui a due anni di tempo da quando il
visore entrato nella mia vita non ne
posso piu fare a me lo faccio quasi
fatica a ricordarmi come era la mia vita
prima di entrare nella realtà virtuale
con questa tecnologia io per esempio
posso style cucina e fare le cose che si
fanno normalmente in cucina oppure
magari includermi un bel film in
televisione seduto comodamente sul
divano bere un bicchiere d'acqua semi ma
l'altra volta sono persino riuscito con
la realtà virtuale a gonfiare un
palloncino ed è questo tipo di
tecnologia di cui stiamo parlando
mi sono arrivate tantissime mail
sull'argomento vigente
scettica che mi ha chiesto ma scusami ma
non potete fare le stesse identiche cose
se il sun visore a che cazzo serve
diffidate da queste persone queste
persone sono quelli che allontanano la
tecnologia allontanano la visione del
futuro con la loro negatività sono le
stesse persone che guarda caso il visore
non se non possono permettere a chi
coincidenza è un domani quando questa
tecnologia sarà comune in tutte le case
italiane
a chi credere the day che vi ricorderete
di chi ha detto no al futuro o di chi è
riuscito addirittura con la realtà
virtuale a leggere un libro qui noi
stiamo parlando di una vera e propria
rivoluzione
e sapete perché mi sono fermamente
convinto di questo perché anche questa
intervista non la sto facendo
seduto qui davanti a voi
ma la sto facendo il bagno con la realtà
virtuale
benvenute però fintato del leccio con
karim usa voi credete nella magia ma non
intendo la magia tipo palle di fuoco
dalle mani o una cicatrice sulla fronte
no no no io intendo proprio la magia che
c'è nella vita di tutti i giorni nelle
cose che non capiamo per esempio tutti
abbiamo un cellulare e in teoria noi
sappiamo il suo funzionamento
tu digiti sul vetro del tuo cellulare il
numero della persona che vuoi contattare
scrivi un messaggio è il messaggio che
arriva è ok ma questo come se tu provi a
chiedere esattamente il come succede
questa cosa qui ad una persona facendo
telo dire nel modo più infantile
possibile lui ti spiegherà che ci sono
delle onde invisibili che viaggiano tra
un cellulare e l'altro ecco questa nella
mia vita e magia tom hardy una foto che
hai nella tua mano nella mano di
un'altra persona che dall'altra parte
del mondo perché delle cose invisibili
viaggiano anche nello spazio contro days
at queste magi queste magia e in questo
momento l'evoluzione tecnologica ha
portato in casa mia un nuovo pezzo di
magia sto parlando della realtà virtuale
e in particolare della htc weil
come avrete già capito io vi parlerò
oggi della htc vai ma vorrei
sottolineare che questo non è un paceman
perché un placement serve per vendere
l'oggetto di cui si sta parlando
ma io sono sicuro che questa cosa non
succederà mai perché ebbe per esempio
perché l'htc weil costa quasi mille euro
visto tutto finito in un attimo ma
siccome io faccio dei video su internet
sono strafamoso in italia e quindi l'htc
mai mi è stato regalato ciao assistenza
di valve potrei avere un htc weil
risposta nella stessa giornata va bene e
che adesso che so che gli state odiando
dall'altra parte che possiamo iniziare
dunque dicevamo virtual reality è una
cosa di cui abbiamo sempre sentito
parlare nei film ma non veniva mai
utilizzata per scopi domestici no sempre
per scopi militari tipo che dalla cucina
di casa tuo potevi comandare un enorme
robot da distruzione per attaccare paesi
amici le solite cose e quindi questa
realtà sembrava molto molto lontana
anche perchè prima sarebbero dovute
arrivare molte più cose tipo nel 2000
sarebbero dovute arrivare le macchine
volanti oppure quel cazzo di computer
volatili quelli ologramma tc in questi
film dove si vedono queste persone che
sono al computer poppando l'aria ma io
lo sento il grido della gente poveraccia
che non ha i soldi manco per andare sul
sito della htc valeva anche solo a
vedere che cos'è che urla a che cazzo
serve
facciamo che me lo dici tutoring a
niente per ora nel senso che per adesso
il focus è stato soltanto sui
videogiochi e iniziamo parlando di
questo in soldoni la realtà virtuale
servirebbe per farti emergere al cento
per cento dentro l'esperienza
videoludica e nel caso della htc viber
non solo esperienza visiva ma anche
sensoriale avendo i due sensori per le
mani quindi questo si potrebbero
visitare i luoghi sconosciuti fare i
viaggi mentali e tripi psichedelici
visitare pianeti mai visti dall'occhio
umano ma per ora abbiamo jobs simulator
il simulatore di lavoro è ironico che
per poterti comprare un sensore della
realtà virtuale per poter giocare a un
gioco che simula un lavoro
dovresti avere un vero lavoro per
poterti permettere mila euro di roba ma
comunque john simulator è per ora
l'esperienza videoludica più carina che
c'è da fare ci sono quattro tipi di
lavoro che tu puoi simulare da dietro un
bancone
l'impiegato il cuoco in meccanico del
cassiere manco che non sono un lavoro
tipo il vigile del fuoco nodo di sei dei
doors l'astronauta noi il cassiere va
bene
l'unica differenza con la vita vera è
che lì è ambientato in un mondo popolato
da schermi del computer volanti e questo
come dicevo prima è il titolo di punta
per adesso per quanto riguarda la realtà
virtuale con i sensori ed è fighissimo
c'è una cosa che chi non ha mai provato
un visore non può capire l'effettiva
esperienza sensoriale nel senso che è
talmente perfetto nel riprodurre i
movimenti della testa e delle mani che
dopo un quarto d'ora 20
aiuti che sei completamente dimenticato
di essere dentro la realtà virtuale e
poi venni lo schermo volante con i baffi
e ti ricordi che forse questo non è il
mondo reale e quando ho cercato di
spiegare questo alle persone che non
hanno mai provato neanche da lontano un
visore la cosa è stata che loro hanno
capito cosa gli ho detto
e cosa intendessi con il fatto che
funzionasse al cento per cento ma non
era chiaro nella loro testa ma poi
provato con le loro stesse mani
ne riparliamo alla fine si parlava
dell'utilizzo del live dei videogiochi
del main abbiamo quindi questo jobs
simulator che dissimula i lavori poi ho
provato un gioco di volo e con gioco di
ruolo intendo la cosa più basilare che
voi potreste pensare per gioco di nuovo
quando poi sei tu stesso a essere dentro
una grotta a tenere con la mano sinistra
la torce con la mano destra spada che
sei tu che devi fare i movimenti con la
spada e lo scheletro non è più dietro lo
schermo mai davanti ai tuoi occhi più
grande di te e cambia tutto cambia
totalmente l'esperienza è anche la cosa
più banale che può essere raccogliere
una moneta da per terra
sei tu che proprio tu devi abbassare con
le ginocchia e con la mano in
raccogliere la moneta da per terra e io
lo so lo sento da qui che voi state
reagendo esattamente come le persone a
cui raccontavo le stesse identiche cose
e si carino capito ma tu mi stai
parlando solo di aprire un baule di
raccogliere le monete
lo so lo so ma se non avete provato non
potete dirlo e le mie esperienze con la
realtà virtuale nei videogiochi più o
meno finiscono qui perché attualmente
una realtà virtuale non ha mercato ma è
ovvio che non ha mercato perché non
nessuno se lo può permettere a 1.000
euro
io non è non ci sono come nei
videogiochi normali vagonate vagonate di
mocciosi che possono strillare a natale
i propri genitori dai papà sgancia la
milan per pagarmi la realtà virtuale e
cosa comportano
nel mercato nessuno che produce per
questo mercato perché nessuno compra per
questo mercato anche se si stanno
ingegnando per fare delle cose ottime
tipo biliardo perché spendere 10 euro
per uscire con gli amici andare
effettivamente a giocare a biliardo
quando poi spendere 1000 e giocare da
casa tua
quando probabilmente un vero tavolo da
biliardo usato con statura e meno oppure
la gente creativa ci sono un sacco di
giochi dove devi sparare agli zombie e
va bene ma ce n'è uno in particolare
dove devi sconfiggere l'invasione di don
morti ma sai che sono veramente felice
di essere in vita in questo periodo
storico e pochissimo altro io ho provato
tanti piccoli giochini tipo virtual
reality fruit ninja e quello è un sogno
veramente di merda che si avvera tutto
simulato alla perfezione per l'amor di
dio ma tutta roba che ci giochi mezzo
pomeriggio e poi la dimentichi io alla
soglia dei 30 anni inizia a pensare in
un modo leggermente diverso da quello
che pensavo anche solo 56 anni fa se
prima quando andavo in un centro
commerciale andavo direttamente nel
reparto di videogiochi
adesso vado si in quello ma mi sposto
anche nel reparto bidoni della
spazzatura perché in casa mia faccio una
differenziata e quindi me ne serve uno
specifico non che si apre così ma di
quelli che spinge se hai capito la mia
domanda è stata siccome questo questa
realtà virtuale funziona alla perfezione
non ci sono altre cose altri campi in
cui si potrebbe usare per fare qualcosa
di veramente figo e qualcosa c'è e si
chiama filt braschi brush è un programma
di disegno anche questo terra terra
basilare come non mai
pensate a paint ma nella realtà virtuale
puoi creare dei capolavori
tridimensionali con niente ma se come
voi non l'avete mai provato io su fatica
spiegarvi effettivamente cosa si prova a
disegnare una linea a mezz'aria e a
poterla vedere in tutte le
non lo so sembra che sembra un bambino a
cui hanno regalato la macchina di batman
per non riesco a spiegarmi
ok vediamo se riesco a spiegarmelo con
un altro esempio allora sono sicuro che
un sacco di voi e che per cosplay chi
per lavoro
disegni abiti e buonissima parte del
lavoro di chi disegna abiti e sul foglio
o in questo caso su un foglio virtuale
al computer dove devi disegnare la
sagoma della persona il vestito che ci
cade sopra eccetera eccetera ecco in
tilt brush come base puoi avere il gusto
di un manichino e poter in tre
dimensioni e nella realtà virtuale
disegnare il tessuto sopra il busto del
tessuto che vuoi del colore che voi
nella forma che vuoi per vedere un
risultato finale che non è solo
bidimensionale su un foglio ma oltre a
disegnare non c'è nient'altro che si può
fare
sì c'è una demo che si può provare che è
ancora in lavorazione quindi sarà finita
tra un po di tempo che ti permette di
vedere virtualmente il catalogo
dell'ikea che tu prendi una cucina che
ti piace
prendi una stanza che vuoi e ci vai
letteralmente dentro ad aprire gli stili
a guardare i colori le altezze scegli la
tua altezza perché così se in scala come
casa tua
scegli il colore così in modo da vedere
se ti piacciono ovvio non è al cento per
cento la stessa cosa come vede la
veramente dentro la stanza tua ma è un
enorme passo avanti su quello che si
potrebbe fare con questa tecnologia
in realtà ci sarebbe un'altra cosa che
sarebbe perfetta per la realtà virtuale
il volo per esempio c'è scusa mi fa viva
più
voi siete ancora di quelle persone che
si masturbano nel modo tradizionale
seduti nella vostra cameretta con la
luce in penombra con la porta chiusa a
chiave
a guardare il video bidimensionale
ragazzi voi non ne avete la minima idea
di porno in 360 gradi nella realtà
virtuale sono avanti sono oltre ciò è
veramente gli stand di limbo a dire che
non ti è mai venuta la curiosità di
sapere cosa ci fosse dietro quello che
stai guardando per esempio guardare la
porta d'ingresso della camera da letto
dove ci sono le due lesbiche con questa
tecnologia
poi finalmente vedere per esempio che
tipo di lampadario c'e nella stanza che
tipo di tappeto e con i sensori puoi
muoverti in un ambiente 3d e guardare
scostando i culi nudi che tipo di
copriletto abbiano e questo tipo di
futuro di cui abbiamo bisogno sentito
più dimensionali sullo schermo cosa
siamo nel 1950 per favore per favore
dovrebbe esserci un po di abitudine da
parte del consumatore e qui mi ricollego
quello che vi dovevo dire prima quello
che ho notato facendo provare i miei
amici
l'htc vai notò in questo gioco puoi fare
quello che vuoi poi si sa fare le
mansioni che ti dicono ma sì a
cazzeggiare perché ogni oggetto al suo
peso e la sua fisica e quello che ho
notato è che al primo approccio non
sapevano bene cosa fare ovviamente
vedevano di avere delle mani virtuale
quindi che ci faccio e nico puoi toccare
tutti gli oggetti che vuoi puoi fare
quello che vuoi in teoria poi man mano
che si abituavano e si dimenticavano di
essere in una realtà virtuale iniziavano
a darsi alla pazza gioia ed è quel che
ho capito
per ora non serve poter viaggiare in
altri pianeti visitare altre città poter
mettersi le ali e volare tra le montagne
della vita no quello che ho visto con i
miei occhi è che la gente vuole fare
quello che non può fare nella vita vera
di tutti i giorni però prendere ogni
singolo oggetto e tirarlo nella cabina
vicina alla tua mettere nella pentola in
cui devi cucinare cose che non puoi
cucinare oppure sostituire il motore di
una macchina con una banana
tutte cose che in teoria potresti anche
fare nella vita vera ma che
fortunatamente il buon senso alla
decenza di fermarti ed è qui che ho
capito che la gente ha solo bisogno di
sfogare la creatività perché mettere una
banana al posto del motore di un'auto
non è creativo è uno sfogo dalla realtà
è come se inconsciamente to quelle cose
le faresti davvero se potessi io
assolutamente non solo uno psicologo
quindi prendete le mie parole per quello
che sono un semplice ragionamento è
questa la vera essenza della fuga
mentale dalla realtà non è andare in un
altro pianeta ma è restare nel tuo mondo
rompendo le regole che cos'è più
appagante uccidere il centesimo alieno
nel centesimo pianeta alieno
lontano lontano dalla terra oppure
investire una persona in cda
e questo perché perché buon senso ce lo
vieta quindi noi mentalmente abbiamo
bisogno di mettere una banana nel motore
perché noi non volevo vivere la vita di
qualcun altro noi vogliamo vivere la
nostra vita ma in modo meno noioso